we're going to start today with two
bloodbaths one that is taking place and
one that could take place a few months
from now the first one is a bloodbath in
the Fox news ratings and I know that
this brings such great pleasure to so
many in my audience some feel bad but
the most important thing is that this is
a bloodbath that is taking place without
any government overreach without any
suppression of anybody's speech or
anything of the sort it is a
self-inflicted bloodbath for Fox News
Fox News has lost half of its audience
since firing Tucker Carlson during that
time slot and there's a lot of different
interesting layers to this and many many
of you have been writing is this the end
of Fox News well no it's not the end of
Fox News but is this the end of Fox News
as we knew it well that's a different
question and we still have to wait and
see
the outcomes of multiple additional
lawsuits that still remain in play even
though the Dominion lawsuit has been
settled for 787 and a half million
dollars uh Salon article it's a
bloodbath Fox News loses more than half
of audience after axing Tucker Carlson
it's not just Tucker's slot writes the
article Sean Hannity and Laura
ingraham's ratings are falling too
hundreds of thousands of Fox News
viewers have switched off the channel
after the network fired top Prime Time
host Tucker Carlson last Monday
substitute host Brian Kilmeade garnered
1.3 million audience members during that
8 pm time slot down
from the 3.05 million viewers who tuned
in to watch Carlson last Wednesday
according to Nielsen ratings The Dip
allowed msnbc's Chris Hayes to overtake
Fox and ratings a popularity contest
that Carlson used to dominate the
conservative host had an average
audience of 3.03 million people for all
of 2022 it was the second most popular
program on cable after Fox's V it is
stunning to me that foxes the five is a
popular show it's almost completely
unintelligible but I guess it doesn't
really matter when you're talking about
Fox News okay we'll get back to that one
approach for comment Fox sent a
statement saying for 21 years it's been
the most watched cable network and it
has a team that's quote trusted more by
viewers than any other news source
a media reporter Brian stelter noted in
a tweet that Fox's audience ratings
plummeted from 2.65 million watching
Carlson's final show to 2.59 Monday 1.7
Million Tuesday 1.3 million Wednesday
what's fascinating about that is that
the relatively high ratings on Monday
which was Tucker's first show gone in
other words Brian kilmeade's first show
is the temporary host there
um there was a lot of curiosity sort of
like a rubber necking how bad is it
going to be it turns out it's really bad
I mean kill meat is not only meaningless
to listen to but also extraordinarily
unentertaining and uncharismatic and
then a lot of people said well if this
is the replacement then I'm out
um and uh it sort of has gotten worse
from there so let's talk about this in a
few different contexts first of all this
isn't one of those oh there's dirty
tricks there's free speech suppression
and people are being uh limited by the
woke mob or whatever else the case may
be as we have now established ad nauseum
Tucker Carlson had good ratings but was
a huge legal risk for Fox and remember
Fox is is unique as a Cable News Network
in that it Garners the vast majority of
its revenues from fees that any of us
who have cable pay
even though I don't watch Fox I have
cable so I can watch the sports and
things like that and
um a couple bucks I guess somewhere
between two and four dollars of my cable
subscription goes to Fox News even
though I don't watch Fox News that makes
Fox different than many of these other
channels in that the other channels
disproportionately rely on ad Revenue so
the the issue with Tucker was not an
issue of
um audience the issue was that he was a
huge legal risk and so what fox decided
to do is to fire Tucker Carlson and I've
already told you the reasons why
Tucker's program partially responsible
for disseminating the allegedly
defamatory content that led to the 787
million dollar settlement with Dominion
responsible to some degree for the
content that led to the ongoing lawsuit
from smartmatic you have a former
staffer of Tucker Carlsons who has filed
a lawsuit for alleged discrimination and
misogyny sexism all sorts of that's a
problem and then you potentially have
another forthcoming lawsuit from Ray
Epps who says that Tucker has made his
life miserable by uh playing up a
conspiracy conspiracy theory in which
Ray Epps is some kind of FBI agent or
actor
instigating the January 6 right so fox
said this is a huge legal headache maybe
one of the ways we can mitigate the
damages we're going to end up having to
pay is by saying we've taken care of
what was one of the problems that caused
these issues for us in the first place
fine Fox News did that no one converts
them into doing that the viewers are mad
and they don't like Brian Kilmeade and
everybody is getting to make their own
decisions nobody's being coerced here
now what's the Counterpoint to all of
this while it's nice to see Fox
suffering not because we want to see
people go hungry or whatever it's nice
to see Fox suffering because they put
out such terrible propaganda that is
actively damaging and corrosive to
American democracy and thinking that
it's good that bad content suffer
it's alarming to see that a bunch of
Fox's audience is not going to say hey
you know what I'm going to get my news
from the AP and Reuters and for
commentary listen to you know I don't
know something much more moderate some
editorial page or whatever the case may
be a lot of the folks furiously tuning
out of Fox News May well end up on even
more extreme unhinged media Outlets like
Newsmax or oan or who the hell knows
what and the United States has a major
problem with people have gotten hooked
on this sort of thing as we've talked
before Fox News in some senses over the
last two years since the 2020 election
became a victim of the monster it
created it knew we now know from text
messages that they were perpetuating
lies about the 2020 election they knew
Trump didn't really win they knew that a
van with sandwiches wasn't really proof
that Trump actually won Michigan or they
knew it but they also knew Their
audience which they've created expects
them to tell those lies and so now we
have a situation where people are
addicted to this stuff and they want
their manufactured outrage they want
their scapegoats they want their you
know lines like they used to get from
Tucker about immigrants make the country
dirtier and whatever else the case may
be and this is everywhere just the other
day I was at a Trader Joe's and there
was a young couple there maybe mid to
late 20s and uh the the guy it was a
heterosexual couple meaning there was a
man and a woman and the a man they were
this is so insane it sounds made up but
it's all too real I was looking for a
particular type of popsicle that my
girlfriend likes it's it's tangerine and
apparently it's seasonal so I was
looking and saying sir ma'am where is it
they didn't have it but in that same
freezer area
there's normally mochi mochi is
delicious absolutely delicious Mochi ice
cream and they were out of the green tea
Mochi ice cream and a guy says to his
girlfriend Joe Biden screwed up the
dairy supply chain and that's why
there's no effing Mochi here and I said
this has to be a I'm sure this guy's
kidding I'm sure this guy is kidding and
I kind of looked over and he wasn't
kidding okay this is just a little
meaningless anecdote about the type of
completely unhinged uh scapegoating and
outrage that the Fox News audience wants
so a real problem for Fox News I'm sure
they will figure it out unless they end
up with billions more in settlements
one of the best ways to support this
show is by supporting our sponsors today
one of those sponsors is sheath
underwear it is spring temperatures are
rising many of us know all too well
about the sweating and the sticking and
the chafing but that's only when you use
traditional underwear when you use
sheath underwear it's no longer a
problem sheath underwear is
ergonomically designed with separate
compartments in the front to keep
everything dry cool and separate and to
keep you comfortable they come in a
zillion different designs something for
everybody the quality is amazing super
long lasting put an end to the
readjusting and the sweating and the
shifting uncomfortably sheath underwear
is really a lifesaver you will thank
yourself it's a unique product you've
got to try at least once to see for
yourself and my audience gets 20 off
with Pacman go to sheathunderwear.com
Pacman the link is down below